the draft in this segment most important
matchups for week three chris you've got
the trivia question fire away all right
here we go on sunday the watt brothers
jj tj and derek will become the second
trio of brothers to play in the same
game the edmonds brothers did that last
year if you remember okay jj and tj both
had exactly 11 and a half sacks at
wisconsin
who had more sacks their rookie year in
the nfl tj or jj
this is a setup because you're going to
expect me to say jj since he was drafted
at a higher level he came in with a
greater pedigree he's got three
defensive player of the year awards my
guess is it's going to be tj is it tj i
believe it is yes tj had seven jj had
five and 5.5 and don't attack me like i
came up with these questions like i'm
trying to jedi mind trick you i don't i
got no control of this
i i'm not i'm not making any accusations
i'm just trying to i'm trying to you
know the very simple binary choice it's
kind of nice to have a flip of the coin
multiple choice with only two choices
that's better than having a blank slate
where you have to come up with a name
that you may not have remembered or even
ever heard of all right let's get
started with this one
plenty of great match-ups this weekend
and uh
what are you looking at your phone did
you write them in your phone yeah i have
notes i have notes that's where i i
emailed them to myself what do you think
i don't have any preparation here i am
going with aaron donald against josh
allen because for as spectacular as josh
allen has been this year he has not had
to face anyone remotely close to aaron
donald in overall capability what
happens to josh allen when aaron donald
blows a hole through the hall that is
the buffalo offensive line and just f's
up the play can josh allen pivot to
something else will he take the bait and
run right at aaron donald to try to
prove dominance like he seems to do over
any defensive player that gets in his
path so that's going to be a fascinating
match up a couple of two-and-oh teams
one of the
emerging quarterbacks against one of the
best defensive linemen of all time
that's what i'm looking forward to yeah
that'll be a good one certainly and
again you know with josh allen he's not
perfect yet we've seen growth in all
areas but we still see
even last week one or two plays where i
just go man don't do that stop it
last week he had the unreal play of
running over a linebacker and then
running over a defensive lineman
and then still going like literally ran
them over like he was jim brown
and then he fumbled the football and
they were lucky to recover it but it's
just things like that where you go it
ain't worth it it's not worth it and i
hope he uh is careful there all right
i think i'm going to the monday night
game i i think the matchup i'm looking
at really is tyreke
versus one of those corners who that
gonna be you know i don't know if it'll
be humphrey or marcus peters but one or
one of the other is going to be matched
up on him and i would bet it's more
humphry i think humphrey is a little bit
better of a true shutdown man-to-man
type corner marcus peters awesome but
also awesome at zone and things like
that and i i just think that is going to
be one of the keys to the football game
because baltimore it's not in their dna
to sit back and play soft zone defenses
they're going to take their chances and
try to force the hand of the game a
little bit and force the game the way
they want it to and on those plays
whoever wins that match up i think can
go a long way to dictating who wins the
football game baltimore blitzes three or
four times in the first half and
on those three or four times tyree kill
gets three or four catches for you know
80 or 90 yards and baltimore is in
trouble they're not gonna win the
football game but if humphrey can get
like just make it one catch or something
like that then you start to go uh-oh
watch out he's got a feel for the routes
tyreek wants to run and they're on top
of them so that's a matchup i look at to
be very influential in the game
yeah absolutely and how you handle tyree
kill goes a long way toward whether to
what extent you can handle the kansas
city offense i am going to
a game
that
i think is going to be critical in
showing which of the two teams is going
to be able to contend this year which
one's ready to step up onto the national
stage and i'm going the washington
football team pass rush against baker
mayfield because
mayfield last week when he didn't face
much pressure up front spectacular week
one when the ravens were coming after
him the exact opposite of spectacular
and and and and this is a parallel for
me because last week i think one of my
picks was the washington football team
front seven against kylo murray and uh
didn't work out so well because he's
kyler murray what can baker mayfield do
against that kind of heat can he get rid
of the ball quickly can he make
decisions quickly can he process
information quickly when he's got chase
young and company coming after him
that's going to go a long way toward
determining whether or not the browns
can can parlay thursday night's win into
a victory on sunday yeah and hopefully
they don't put him in those situations
over you know too much because as you
talked about all before last week's game
and even the week before that i mean the
best weapon they got is nick chubb in
that run game so run the damn ball
washington hasn't had to play an offense
in the first two games it can run the
ball like cleveland can and that'll be
interesting and you know i think that
could slow down that front four too but
you're right that washington front four
you know they can cause two or three
mistakes from a quarterback who can you
know it can end up costing you the
football game um
i'm gonna go to dallas in seattle
because i can't wait to see zeke versus
jamal that's where i'm pumped to see
they're gonna have some showdowns you
know they will there's no doubt jamal
adams i think is blitzing more than any
person i see in football right now i
mean they're bringing him so a lot of
the times the running back and pass
protection
is assigned to
that db or somebody that might blitz
like that and those are two guys that
don't know what it means to step out of
the way or
don't take it i mean they bring it both
of them so i'm excited to see that and
then of course we're going to see some
showdowns in the run game too i mean
zeke elliott backs down from nobody he's
gonna bring it first time i ever met
knew about him was him in that preseason
game where tony romo hurt his back he
was running over cam chancellor and i
was like wait nobody does that to cam
chancellor so i'm very excited to see
those two stubborn tough uh football
players go at it
could go a long way toward determining
who wins the game too because if you
shut down ezekiel elliott you make the
cowboys one-dimensional yeah uh maybe
that plays well it's still that seahawks
defense isn't what it was i know yeah
it's not the same we'll see but at least
jamal adams will be playing the pass as
well right all right this one for me
and and can we stipulate that
tom brady now playing for the
buccaneers it's likely he's not going to
play for any other team ever this is it
for him right with the buccaneers until
he's done
so yes yes okay
if that's the case
then this will be
tom brady's last trip ever
to denver
tom brady versus denver is the matchup
i'm interested in because in 17 prior
visits to denver he is eight and nine
this is his chance to finish his career
at a mere 500 in denver the greatest
quarterback of all time is below 500
when playing in denver the good news
nova miller no drew lock no cortland
sutton and i'd like to think tom brady
versus jeff driscoll advantage tom brady
but
whatever it is it's got to be something
right it's got to be chris yeah i this
is his chance to get to 500 and even
then it's gonna be weird to think nine
and nine in 18 career games against
denver in denver yeah no you're right
but you know through his 20-year career
denver had a few stints of being a
really damn good football team and a
team that
you know had a defense there for a
period of time that was like okay we're
not scared of you tom brady and then of
course the peyton manning thing and all
that and their ability so all right last
pick for me
i i want to do mcveigh the mix versus
the mix mcvay versus mcdermott but you
already visited that game and i'm very
interested about i won't do that i'll
tell you another one i'm really
interested in the pats front seven
versus the raiders o line the raiders o
line is an immovable force the way they
moved the saints last week josh jacobs
if i have a concern about the patriots
team the only one is right now they're
front seven they lack big people there's
no dante hightower they're lack speed
linebacker things like that i i i could
see a way where the raiders just control
the game with their run game and make
this game very very close so uh i'm i
want to see how that shakes out i'm
picking the patriots but i think that
could be an interesting part to watch
for
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports